ou partir en France vous vous êtes déjà
posé la question on imagine et bien
aujourd'hui nous allons classer les les
différentes destinations française vous
voyez c'est les top 30 du Figaro ce top
30 que nous allons faire on va enlever
le son de mon ordinateur bien sûr on va
classer les destinations de France
métropolitaine et pour ça je suis
accompagné des meilleurs du Figaro sur
la question bonjour Valérie Sasportas
bonjour bonjour F despl bonjour Vincent
et bonjour flurent maillet bonjour
Vincent bonjour à tous merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hu jourd'hui j'inite no
internautes bien sûr à poser leurs
questions à faire à nous dire un peu ce
que eux pour eux c'est quoi leur top 30
des destinations françaises on va
expliquer le fonctionnement de ce live
devant nous on a ce petit pot dans
lequel il y a un peu plus de 30 non 35
exactement et nos invités du jour vont
venir piocher les uns après les autres
et le premier sera premier mais ensuite
on va faire le classement petit à petit
Philippe est-ce que vous voulez bien
commencer à tirer un petit bout de
papier alors comme c'est ce qui était
prévu je je m'exécute ah oui il'était un
peu préparé s regarder alors la BoM la
BoM alors lequel de vous trois veut en
parler de la la BoM al on on attaque
fort avec la BoM et nos moyens
technologiques absolument démesurés donc
la main innocente de Philippe a pioché
quand même une destination la BA de
Somme où on est essentiellement autour
de la de la nature et puis une
destination qui est quand même prisée
des Parisiens une destination qui est
plutôt à mon sens une destination de de
de weekend pourquoi parce que la BA
somme bah c'est une somme justement de
de de petit village je à saint-valée en
C si je dis pas de B saint-valérie voilà
exactement donc une somme de petit
village avec un un écosystème naturel
assez assez incroyable la faune la flore
des Maré donc c'est un lieu assez couru
de villégiature à Paris mais pas que et
puis c'est près de d'autres sites assez
assez remarquables qu'on va pas qu'on va
pas citer maintenant pour pas défleurer
le reste du classement mais la BA somme
c'est une approche qui est quand même
intéressante celle-ci dans dans le top
30 j'ai aucun doute qu'elle doit y
figurer elle doit figurer elle fera pas
parti de celles qui vont partir non et
c'est c'est une belle destination comme
dit Florent il y a un très beau littoral
qui est assez sauvage paradoxalement
exactement c'est-à-dire qu' il y a pas
de route au bord de la mer on l'atteint
en traversant des dunes des des petits
ponts des des passages et cetera c'est
assez bobo hein il faut dire quand même
un peu ce qu' est surtout parce qu'il y
a une grosse clientè parisienne qui
croit faire un peu d'écologie en allant
se balader là-bas mais en dehors de ça
si on passe ce qui est pas forcément à
d'ailleurs mais si on passe là-dessus
c'est une destination qui est qui est
agréable euh et qui est surtout très
accessible pas très cher hein il y a des
des hôtels il y a un ou deux hôtels
quatre quatre étoiles mais sinon il y a
des petites adresses assez sympathiques
c'est très calme on est un peu au bout
de nulle part hein c'est c'est hop voilà
ça fait partie de ces destinations où on
se dit après bah c'est plus la France VO
on s'y balade on peut y voir des focs et
oui la saison quand c'est c'est la
saison et puis on on va pas se mentir on
y va pas pour le soleil particulièrement
donc on on y va pour le char àoile quand
même c'est une super destination de
weekend pour le sport aussi pour le char
àile effectivement on y va pas forcément
pour le soleil mais il y en aura
d'autres dans ce dans ce classement
Valérie est-ce que vous voulez piocher
le deuxième petit bout de papier je
pioche
île de léron et î deay et îedex et oui
les trois îles euh alors moi j'avais
rajouté l'îedex dans le dans le dans le
choix qu'on avait fait parce que je
trouve que des trois c'est la évidemment
la la plus méconnue et c'est assez drôle
parce que c'est là où Napoléon euh a
passé sa dernière nuit avant d'être
exilé à Saint-Hélène et on y trouve une
un quelque chose de tout à fait
improbable c'est la maison de de
Napoléon que l'on peut visiter euh avec
des collections du Premier Empire qui
sont assez belles assez formidables tout
ça est rattaché à M maison d'ailleurs au
musée de la Melle maison euh à à à rue
mal maison et en fait le un des fans de
Napoléon c'était le Barau gourgot et le
baron gourgaot vers 1900 a épousé une
très riche Américaine et avec l'argent
de sa femme il a passé sa vie à racheter
des des choses qui avaient qui avaient
trait à Napoléon et du coup ça for
mamusé un peu un peu étrange parce que
on est on est un peu on est sur une
toute petite île hein où il y a pas de
voiture il y a pas de voiture il y a pas
de voiture il y a un seul hôtel enfin
c'est vraiment le bout du monde c'est
l'antil î de Ray hein c'est vraiment
l'antil î de Ray justement alors dans ce
classement on va essayer de faire un un
on va on va faire un on va classer les
trois en même temps donc il faut qu'on
sache alors selon vous est-ce que
l'ildeck c'est déjà la meilleur des des
trois alors moi je vais m'intéresser à
l'histoire un peu plus un peu plus
contemporaine he mais c'est aussi dans
dans ce dans ce siâge là qu'on a
forbyard une émission populaire moi je
être là aussi pour défendre un peu les
les destinations populaires et les plus
petites histoires mais mais forbyer
c'est c'est pas l'île de non c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas l'ildex mais on est
dans ce dans ce périmètre là on est on
est
entreou
ex doncex pour l'ajouter moi je suis
d'accord parce que c'est une destination
qui se fait à la journée essentiellement
comme a souligné Philippe il y a un seul
hôtel je suis pas sûr qu'il faille
réserver plus de 2 ans à l'avance
peut-être pour avoir une place donc on y
va la journée effectivement il y a pas
de voiture c'est sympa on est à vélo
c'est des paysans voilà c'est des
paysans et c'est complémentaire à mon
sens de l'île de léron je suis moins sûr
que ça soit qu'on soit sur le moi je te
rejoins je rejoins là-dessus sur l'île
de l'île de Ray l'Î de
c'est très très à part mais Oleron est
moins guindé que ré c'est ce que nous
avions écrit d'ailleurs dans le Figaro
oui Oleron est moins guindé que ré bah
oui oui forcément les rond d'abord c'est
un peu plus loin oui euh c'est moins
accessible
euh et l'île de Ray bah c'est vraiment
alors ça ça c'est c'est vraiment alors
là pour le coup c'est c'est Paris c'est
le 21e arrondissement de Paris hein on
va à l'île de Ré on reste à l'île de Ré
est-ce qu'il faut mettre les trois
ensemble alors si vous voulez on peut
mettre l'île deoléron et l'Î d'ex l'îon
c'est aussi la plus grande île de la
côte atlantique alors c'est
intéressantou c'est vrai aussi alors
est-ce que la question c'est si on
rassemble l'Î de léron et l'Î deex on
l'IM où par rapport à la BoM est-ce que
vous préférez partir en weekend î
dOléron ildex ou en bom bah je trouve
que l'Î deex c'est plus original c'est
moins
connu c'est moins cher c'est plus
authentique et il y a à la fois de la
mer il y a de la balade il y a de
l'histoire on place au dessus oui c'est
pas toujours je serais pas toujours
d'accord avec tout ce que vous dites
mais là je suis d'accord et bien voilà
notre nos deux premiers qui sont classés
Florent vous pouvez y
aller et bien nous allons parler à
présentp du lac d'Any ah le lac d'y
Florent est-ce que vous V en parler
alors je peux bien vous en parler du lac
d'y parce que c'est c'est pas très loin
c'est pas très loin de chez moi lac d'y
alors alors c'est c'est très large le
lac d' donc il y a la ville d' il y a
plein de de de villages autour je vais
plutôt vous parler d'un coup de cœur
autour du du du du lac d'Any parce que
chez l'oncle de chez ton
oncle non mais c'est mais c'est pas
grave autour du du lac d'y parce que la
ville d'y en elle-même les les plaines
sont quand même maintenant assez
récurrentes vous y allez en toute saison
il y a du monde et cetera donc moi je
vais plutôt vous recommander un petit
village taloir montmine voilà qui qui
est sur les les bords du lac Dancy qui
est tout à fait charmant il y a le col
de la forc là derrière avec des des des
formidables balades le lac Dany à mon
sens c'est un lieu qui est assez unique
en France euh parce que vous avez ce lac
d'une pureté qui est quand même
incroyable où il y a un nombre
d'activités touristiques également assez
incroyable et vous êtes entouré de
montagne c'est un c'est un un panorama
qui est quand même relativement unique
je pense et puis depuis cette année on
peut faire le tour du lac complet euh à
vélo alors j'ai pas vérifié mais
apparemment ils ont bouclé effectivement
proet qui est quand même incroyable hein
parce que c'est assez rare qu'on puisse
faire parce que généralement il y a il y
a des il y a toujours un ponton privé
qui empêche de ça et là euh ils ont fait
une espèce de oui une espèce de piste
cyclable alors on peut le faire à vé on
p le faire à pied aussi mais quand même
tout le tour du lac ça c'est quand même
un atout hein alors les mauvaises
langues vous vous diront que c'est aussi
un peu l'autoroute maintenant entre les
piétons les vélos les vélos assistance
électrique les rollers également qu'il a
beaucoup de sportifs on de savoir donc
les les gens ils s'entraînent et cetera
le lac d'an moi j'ai aucun doute que
c'est un site qui est formidable
j'aurais plutôt tendance à dire et par
rapport à ce que soulignait Philippe
tout à l'heure sur l'index que je le
verrai pas très haut parce que à mon
sens il y a une mauvaise gestion des des
flux des flux touristiques mais c'est
mon avis hein ah donc on le mettrait
plus bas que l'idolérant
l'ilddeex qu'est-ce qu'il a il y aura
d'autres d'autres dtinations euh on au
début attention là est montagnes mais
est-ce qu'on a la possibilité de changer
de classement après ah oui on on pourra
faire des ajustements si vous voyez que
le classement ne vous convent pas du
tout mettre à la 10e position ah non non
non non pour l'instant pour l'instant on
le classe les uns par rapport aux autres
Philippe tout ah ou question c'estce
qu'on met en dessous en dessous de la B
audessus de la B ouess do je mettrame
moi je mettrais en dessous de la bê som
qu en D de la bê Valérie vous êtes
d'accord de moi je l'aurais mis audessus
mais oui ça c'est bon vous vous aurez
les bons arbitrages la prochaine fois on
est démocrate nous sommes en démocratie
vous êtes un montagnard ça oui et puis
et puis voilà c'est ce qu'on disait
c'est que Florent va défendre un peu ce
chacun façon ici va défendre
savoyardm Philippe alisy pour le pour le
4e nom à tirer
hop ah château de Pierrefond al château
de Pierrefond c'est un lieu fait
rajouter dans cetteou fait rajouter
parce que c'est un lieu qui est un peu
méconnu alors c'est un lieu qu'il faut
plutôt fréquenter en automne c'est en
pleine forêt de Compigne c'était le un
lieu de villégiature de la famille
impériale donc de Napoléon I de
l'impératrice Eugénie et c'est Napoléon
I qui a fait restaurer ce chef-dœuvre
par Violet le Duc et c'est devenu un
chef-dœuvre de l'arme médiéval c'est
peut-être un des rares châteaux dans le
monde qui est tel qu' aurait pu être au
Moyen-âge et donc très très complet
alors évidemment c'est un château vide
euh très compliqué à visiter enfin à
faire visiter pour ce pour ceux qui qui
l'animent parce que il y a évidemment il
y a des pièces absolument immenses et
puis il a jamais été habité c'est une
j'allais dire c'est une construction
neuve mais presque hein puisqu'il a été
fini à la fin du second temp donc vers
1870 et encore je suis pas sûr qu'il
était totalement terminé quand le quand
le Napoléon I a été chassé du trône mais
ça reste quand même un lieu un peu
magique c'est parce que c'est énorme
c'est c'est un lieu de vision c'est
quand on arrive on est saisi par cette
espèce de masse toutes ces tours et
cetera c'est c'est Disney mais un Disney
avant Disney et un vrai et en vrai un
vrai Disney est est-ce que vous y êtes
déjà allé non mais il donne envie d'y
aller il donne très envie d'y aller
château vide à visiter à l'automne ça me
donne un peu moins envie mais bon
pourquoi
pas c'est non non mais c'est un c'est
oui alors après
effectiv voilà c'est un site c'est un
site c'est pas un c'est pas
effectivement un château effectivement
vous avez raison il est il est vide donc
voilà mais c'est un site c'est un site
prodigieux c'est un décor et c'est un
décor dans la nature mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'il est vide il est vide parce
qu'il na jamais été meublé parce que
c'est trop immense alors il y a eu un
temps où on a voulu en faire un musée du
Second Empire et où on projetait de de
ramener euh de Londres où ils sont
l'empereur Napoléon II l'impératrice
Eugénie et le prince impérial et on
voulait les inhumer au sein du château
et créer autour un musée du Second
Empire puis à l'époque le le ministre de
la Culture a tranché avec le musée
d'orset en disant il peut pas y avoir
deux musées du 19e siècle dans la même
région et cetera et enfin c'est pas la
même région puisque c'est les haut
France pense mais en tout cas aussi
proche l'un de l'autre euh voilà donc
c'est un lieu qu'il faut considérer
comme un site et d'ailleurs il avait été
un peu conçu comme ça parce que quand il
y avait des séries à compienne les
fameuses séries impériales où la la
famille impériale séjournit à compienne
pendant une semaine c'était une
excursion c'estàdire on allait en
charaban à travers la forêt et il y a
d'ailleurs une route qui s'appelle la
route Eugénie qui relie le château de
compienne par le parc au château de
pierrefo c'est cette même route qu'on
empruntait avec les invités pour aller
leur le chantier de pierref qui était à
l'époque le chantier du siècle donc il
faut le considérer comme un site et pas
autre chose alors où est-ce qu'on le
classe j'ai l'impression qu'il n'y a que
Philippe qui va pouvoir savoir où
classer moi je le classerai après NC
parce que c'est pas non plus un site
majeur on est d'accord c'est un site
voilà mais vous avez au moins cette
cette petite idée allez-y Valérie vous
pouvez piocher ce 4è bout de papier où
partons-nous maintenant nous partons il
y a beaucoup de monde là où nous partons
ah nous partons au mont-smichel nous
partons au montsmichel parlez-nous du
monts-michel alors c'est c'est moi j'ai
fait un reportage sur le monts-michel où
j'étais assez dur avec le monts-michel
parce que le monts-michel c'est vraiment
les galeries lafillette à l'horizontale
le premier jour des soldes euh il y a à
peu près je crois 3 millions de
visiteurs c'est ce qu'ils annon cette
année voilà ce qui est absolument énorme
et il y a une seule rue qui fait euh à
peu près 4 m de large et qui est
encombré de marchands du temple euh avec
des produits mdinchina et cetera alors
il y a eu beaucoup de projets qui ont
été faits d'abord pour désenclaver le
monts-michel pour le pour lui lui rendre
la mer hein puisqueavant les voitures
stationnaient au pied du monts-michel
alors on a on a désensemblé tout ça on a
créé une nouvelle dig et cetera bon mais
enfin ça n'enlève pas la fréquentation
par contre il y
a une solution parce que en fait les
gens vont quand ils vont au monts-michel
ils vont voir le monts-michel et puis il
ne il il reste en bas je crois qu'il y a
20 % des visiteurs qui vont jusqu'en
haut d'cord or c'est juste c'est en haut
que c'est le plus intéressant parce que
en haut il y a la fameuse abaye et qui
est une splendeur qui dépend d'ailleurs
des la Réunion des Musées na c'est an
qui fait peut-être ses 1000 ans cette
année et et dans cet abée la la la
spiritualité de l'abayli est aux mains
de d'une communauté je crois que c'est
la communauté des de Jérusalem et euh et
al ce sont des moines euh qui sont en
Bur et alors on peut assister à des
offices he qui sont en robe de Bur on
peut assister à des offices et alors là
il y a un petit côté Au nom de la rose
he parce quand vous êtes moi ça m'est
arrivé que vous êtes en fin de journée
perché sous l'archange Gabriel au fin
enfin au sommet de la au sommet de du
monts-michel à écouter ses moines
psalmodiers et C c'est c'est assez
émouvant c'est assez beau et il y a
d'ailleurs quelque chose qui est
intéressant c'est que on peut dormir on
peut aussi faire une une retraite alors
c'est une retraite qui est très ouverte
c'est pas du prosélitisme euh mais
disons une retraite plus de silence
voilà encadré par ces moines dans leur
logie donc c'est un peu évidemment c'est
c'est c'est pas c'est pas du grand luxe
mais ça permet de dormir au monts-michel
ce qui ce qui est assez rare parce qu' y
a il y a qu'un hôtel et il y a très peu
de chambres je crois qu'il y a une
dizaine de chambres dans cet hôtel et là
on peut dormir on peut dormir chez avec
chez les moines et euh et euh et du coup
on profite bah du du Mont sa-michel
quand il y a plus personne c'està-dire
tard le soir ettin prilège par je me
souviens d'un d'un reportage un peu plus
ancien que le vôtre et en dormant au au
montsmichel on évite la foule il il
suffit il suffit on peut jouer un peu
avec les horaires par contre pour
l'abaye est fermé les alors là où il y a
le moins de monde c'est quand l'abaye
est fermé malheureusement ou pas elle
sera fermée le 25 décembre c'est dans
quelques jours et le 1er janvier comme
le 1er mai ce sont les TR jours de fer
fermeture si on veut éviter la foule on
y va ces jours-là mais on ça permet pas
de vivre non plus on perd le cô don PhIP
par de ce que vous me disiez j'ai
l'impression que le montre Saint-Michel
c'est peut être très sympa mais c'est
aussi un peu
surpuplé c'est la capitale du sur
tourisme capitale du sur tourisme en
France estce que alors là-dessus ouais
moi je je alors déjà Philippe nous nous
montre à quel point on peut découvrir
les sites sous des des des jours et des
approches qui sont qui sont différentes
je pense que le le le vrai sujet parce
qu'on est là pour classer les plus
belles destinations françaises bah
là-dessus je pense qu'on tombera tous
d'accord pour dire que c'est un site qui
est vraiment exceptionnel la vraie
question c'est quand est-ce qu'on va le
voir est-ce qu'on accepte de le voir
sous la pluie est-ce qu'on accepte de le
voir le matin avec des magasins fermés
de ne pas ramener son petit souvenir et
cetera et je crois que dans cette
condition là je je me vois pas mettre le
mon Saint-Michel en bas du classement
c'est pas c'est pas possible c'est la
rçon de sa gloire c'est parce que c'est
l'une des plus belles destination
française qui oui mais ça rentte moi la
question que j'ai envie poser c'est si
vous préférez partir dire en un weekend
est-ce que vous préférez aller au
monts-michel ou à l'île de Lon ou l'île
d'ex tout dépend quand en général mais
c'est pas la même nature des
destinations fait pas la même chose au
montsmichel ça
dép là où Florent a raison c'est qu'on
peut pas le mettre c'est c'est un des
enfin c'est un des sites emblématiques
du tourisme en France dans le monde donc
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas le mettre
c'est comme si on mettait la tour flel
en dernière position des sites à voir
quand on vient à on raisonne sur les
petits sites c'est le plus vu après
Paris oui c'est serit grotesque donc
effectivement il faut le il faut le
monter il faut le mettre avant an
peut-être ou avant la BA som avant la B
ça moi je le mettrai je le mettrai en
numéro 1 moi personnra aussi en numéro 1
en numéro
1 c'est en numéro 1 alors c'est le site
qui est extrêmement connu à l'étranger
qui véhicule aussi une certaine une
certaine idée de la France une certaine
image de la France aussi la France la
France des océans la France spirituelle
Philippe l'a souligné la France
historique spirituelle de la
spiritualité
h alors allez-y Florent on va piocher
pour parce qu'il faut avancer tout de
même dans dans cette émission on a
encore pas mal de choses à canancer on
se trouvait bah écoutez on va rester à
l'ouest hein puisque je viens de tirer
belle île en mer belle île en mer belle
île en mer est c'est une meilleure
destination que toutes cell qu'on a tiré
jusque là ça donne envie ça donne envie
de freudonner mais je crois que ce qu'on
peut dire sur belle île en mer je crois
pas dire de bêtisse en disant que c'est
une des plus grandes îles également de
la façade de la façade ouest de voir
c'estes 17 km belle île en mer bah c'est
un endroit qui c'est un endroit qui est
qui est fabuleux qui qui participe aussi
à l'engouement qu'on a pour euh pour
pour la Bretagne pour ces régionsl ça
fait ça fait rêver c'est aussi un site
alors j'ai l'impression qu'on va se
répéter à chaque fois mais c'est aussi
un site qui est très trop couru
malheureusement au beau jour donc c'est
un site qui mérite de se retrouver en
haut du classement mais c'est aussi un
site qui mérite et qu'on répète qu'on
peut découvrir tout à fait hors saison
même si c'est une île donc par
définition difficile d'accès euh en tout
cas hors de la haute saison justement
mais c'est évidemment un site un site
incroyable exceptionnel Valérie pour moi
belleî en mer est une chanson B en mer
est une chanson ah donc ce'est pas c'est
pas bonne endroit euh vous où
voulez-vous le mettre
Florent on va vous laisser la main sur B
en mer est-ce qu'on le mettrait
au-dessus de l'île d' léron et l'île
d'ex je je le le le binôme fait que non
mais écoutez moi je le mettrai quand
même audessus de la BA somme audessus de
la BA de Somme moi je suis allé il y a
pas si longtemps à en j'ai trouvé ça
quand même assez incroyable comme
endroit donc je suis d'accord pour le
mettre en tout audessus de la bomme mais
je ne suis pas censé prendre parti dans
ce dans ce dans ce classement Philippe
alleisy vous pouvez tirer ça manquait ah
ouais
alors château de versaill ah le château
de versaill alors avant de parler du
château de Versailles j'ai un petit
commentaire de Sophie dans les qui nous
dit je compte les jours avant de quitter
les evelines puisque je ne m'y plais pas
donc avant de parler du château de
versaill mais bon plutôt globalement
mais le château de versaill vendez-le
nous alors bah c'est pas besoin de moi
pour être pour être vendu alors le
château de Versailles c'est un peu comme
le monts-michel c'est-à-dire que la
difficulté c'est de savoir quand est-ce
qu'on va le visiter à quel moment et
cetera euh château de Versailles bah
c'est alors il y a il y a le château par
par lui-même qui est quelque chose
évidemment d'extraordinaire qui est une
réunion de de du meilleur de de l'art
français au 17e et 18e siècle mais moi
je dirais que le château de Versailles
je dirais qu'à Versailles il y a une
grâce la grâce de versaill vraiment et
euh est-ce que c'est lié au fait de la
fin tragique de ceux qui l'ont habité
peut-être mais on est on est pénétré
d'une certaine nostalgie quand on va
quand on va à Versailles et une
nostalgie d'une d' la fois de la de la
grandeur de la France et d'une certaine
intimité aussi euh de ceux qui ont fait
l'histoire et qui n'ont habité
et évidemment la cette grâce de
Versailles on la retrouve beaucoup dans
le parc à certaines heures du jour euh
avec une certaine lumière je me souviens
d'une fois au d'une chambre du Trianon
Palace avoir vu le château comme ça
euh sur enfin au bout d'une d'une d'une
d'une immense verdure comme ça on voit
cette barre orangée dans le soleil
couchant c'est quelque chose de vraiment
de de de de de de magique en fait c'est
quelque chose quelque chose d'étonnant
alors après on a quand même parce que
dans le Figaro Magazine nous avions fait
un un grand sujet sur
l'Hôtel du grand contrôle qui est le
seul hôtel qui est à l'intérieur du
domaine de Versailles dans lequel on
peut dormir depuis depuis 2 ans qui app
partient au groupe leserel qui un hôtel
de luxe très cher hein il y a 15
chambres c'est à peu près 2000 € 2000 €
la nuit mais enfin l'expérience est
extraordinaire parce que avec cet hôtel
entre autres privilèges puisque quand on
parle de versaill il faut parler de
privilège sinon ça n'a aucun intérêt et
quand on entre autres privilèges à
Versailles dans cet hôtel on peut aller
se promener dans l'orangerie la nuit
monter l'escalier des sans marches alors
évidemment il y a une grille il y a des
grilles au bout des deux escaliers des
sans marches mais enfin on peut quand
même se promener dans l'orangerie tout
seul la nuit euh puisque c'est ouvert
avec avec l'hôtel du grand contrôle qui
était l'ancien hôtel du contrôleur des
finances du roi et qui appartenait à
l'armée pour faire et qui a été
rétrocédé au domaine de Versailles qui a
décidé sous Jean-Jacques aayagon d'en
faire d'en faire un hôtel et et il y a
un autre privilège qui vous est donné
quand vous dormez dans cet hôtel c'est
que vous pouvez aller visiter euh le
Trianon ou euh le
le les appartements du roi ou les
appartements de la reine avant
l'ouverture ou après la fermeture avec
un guide spécial alors c'est compris
dans c'est compris dans le prix ce qui
explique que le prix c'est très cher
mais enfin il y a là encore quelque
chose de magique d'aller à Trianon avec
qure personnes en fait versaill convoque
l'imaginaire pardon je trouve que
Versailles convoque l'imaginaire ou que
c'est une destination d'abord c'est un
château qui ressemble à si on demande à
un enfant de dessiner un château il fait
celui de versaill il va celui il va
faire celui de Versailles et quand il va
découvrir versaillil il va avoir
l'impression d'entrer dans son château
parce qu'il l'a dessiné comme ça et puis
c'est devenu un nom commun c'est DESS
comme c'est comme le pourquoi versaill
correspond à l'imaginaire de tous les
enfants du monde en fait et c'est assez
extraordinaire alors j'ai juste
compléter et ça donne
pardon ça donne une certaine idée une
certaine idée de la France une certaine
idée de la grandeur de la France de la
beauté et tous ces ébénistes qui ont
réalisé les meubles qui qui pour le coup
là ça n'est pas un château vide c'est un
pourquoi est-ce qu'on cela convoque
l'imaginaire parce qu'on peut imaginer
en plus ça donne envie d' disais il une
intimité intimité qui est lié à la
grandeur et cela donne envie aux plus
jeunes d'apprendre l'histoire d'ailleurs
on devrait toujours avoir des cours
d'histoire dans les châteaux c'est c'est
une grandeur je pense qu'on on s'éloigne
un peu du sujet c'est une grandeur à
quoi sert le voyage bien sûr le voyage
sert l'histoire et la
géographie ça sert ça sert ça sert plein
de choses le voyage voilà pour compléter
ce qu'a dit Sophie et ce qu'on dit M mes
collègues évidemment prénom évidemment
non Sophie CIT c'était la lectrique
pardon excusez-moi excusez-moi de suivre
he voilà euh donc Sophie qui regrettait
de vivre dans les Yvelines alors euh
c'est de voir à quel point le le le
château de Versailles façonne plus que
l'imaginaire il y a des règles
d'urbanisme qui font qu'autour du
château de versaill et dans les Yvelines
euh vous allez ne pas trouver d'immeuble
de plus de R2 R3 étages et cetera parce
qu'on garde la vue d'origine du château
de Versailles ce qui est quand même
assez extraordinaire donc petite
parenthèse pour Sophie elle trouvera
certainement un horizon plus bouché dans
d'autres départements et par rapport à
ce que disait euh Philippe Philippe et
Valérie moi j'ajouterai que le le
château de Versailles on a aboli les
privilèges donc il y a certains
privilèges et et et pourquoi pas mais ça
reste une destination qui est
incroyablement populaire c'est plus de 7
millions de visiteurs chaque année c'est
des spectacles je pense aux grandes zo
nocturnes qui sont devenus
formidablement attrayants qui attirent
beaucoup de monde de tous horizons il y
a pas que des étrangers il y a aussi des
gens de versaill des gens de d'Île de
France évidemment des gens de de
province et heureusement et puis c'est
un site qui continue se dévoiler je
parle sous le contrôle de de Philip qui
connaît le sujet beaucoup mieux que moi
mais c'est le le le amameau de la reine
qui vient d'être d'être d'être rénové on
redécouvre Versailles en permanence donc
ce château qui date d' y a plus de de de
de 300 ans on continue de le redécouvrir
c'est incontestablement le site
emblématique pour moi de la France et
bien on va CER tout en on va le mettre
tout en haut je le mets tout de suite
tout en haut allez-y Florent pour
piocher notre 7e notre notre notre notre
8e non notre 8e nom maintenant par que
vous voyez le le top 3 château de
Versailles le Mont-Michel iléron ex et
bien je vous renvoie à l'ouest puisqu'on
a Nant et 30ente mou ah Nant et trente
mou Nant assez connu trente mou petit V
village de pêcheur à côté beaucoup moins
beaucoup moins connu mais je sais que
Philippe c'est to c'est Philippe qui
avait fait du prosellitis pour 30 mous
non ah pas du tout moi j'ai jamais mis
les pieds à 30 mous en tout cas moi
l'alliage me paraît me paraît
intéressant entre la la grande ville
dont on va pas débattre ici de savoir si
elle est en BR n pas et parce qu'on l'
pas fait non plus sur le mon
Saint-Michel donc on va pas non plus
faire pour Nant a priori et les petits
et les petits à côté et les petits à
côté quand on découvre une destination
bah c'est aussi d'avoir l'opportunité
voilà on disait tout à l'heure l'dex on
y passera pas 3 jours Nant on peut y
passer évidemment beaucoup plus de temps
et l'intérêt c'est d'aller visiter les
environs les environs c'est
effectivement les villages comme trmous
qui se singularisent par le côté coloré
et cetera et puis ça fait ça fait un
séjour qui est quand même intéressant
qui est pas seulement urbain et culturel
h mais non tu es en voyage alors je ne
veux pas pas à chaque fois faire de ces
phrases là mais c'est le voyage à Nant
c'est un c'est quand même oui quand même
Philippe c'est un musée à ciel ouvert il
y a ces grandes machines qui sont quand
même extraordinaires avec alors les Nant
sont pas sont pas tout à fait sur la
même ligne puisque ce qui reproche au
Voyage à Nantes c'est que le voyage à
Nant aurait pourrait être partout
c'est-à-dire qu'on apporte de
l'extérieur de Nant toute une série de
de de rendez-vous culturels qui n'ont
que peu de choses à voir avec N comme
par exemple Mach qu'on VI voir et pas
ailleurs oui c'est un Nant qu'on vient
les voir mais c'est assez décrié he ou
effectivement les machines les machine
de Nant ça pourrait être partout oui
mais là elles sont à Nant elles sont à
Nant sur Mme ass original moi je je vous
rejoint Philippe sur le fond maintenant
en terme d'intérêt de séjour ça ça
participe quand même à réhausser un
petit peu l'intérêt de la destination de
dant que les Nant l'aime pas c'est une
chose là on s'adresse aux gens qui on
qui ont envie de visiter des lieux alors
les automates aujouri je pousserai pas
je pousserai pas les gens à aller à
aller à Nantes parce que c'est une
destination qui a beaucoup souffert de
de d'un d'un certain environnement qui
est assez étouffante alors que c'était
une ville qui était recherchée justement
pour sa qualité de vie et quand on
arrive à Nantes il a il y a des grues
partout il y a un urbanisme absolument
prodigieux et et je trouve que ce n'est
ce n'est plus la destination agréable
telle qu'elle existait jusque dans les
années j que dans les années 90 il y a
souvent comme ça des des
destinations qui qui ont été gagnées par
leur succès et dont le succès que le
succès a fini par dénaturer c'est assez
paradoxal mais mais c'est comme ça on
venait à Nant chercher ce qu'on ne
trouvait pas à Paris de
l'espace un bonir de la proximité de la
chaleur de la de la chaleur humaine de
la de la sécurité et cetera et puis au
bout au bout du compte bah on se
retrouve dans une ville qui n'est plus
si agréable à vivre que ça Yv qui nous
dit Nant pas du tout mais 30 m est joli
pour se balader alors Nant où est-ce
qu'on le classe selon vous oh làdessus
je pense qu'on va
être d'accord pour le
mettre pas sûr que N c'est pas une
destination malheureusement l'art ne
fait pas une destination voilà alors
c'est c'est à Philippe de de tirer dans
tes désolé les Nant grotte de Lasco
alors moi j'ai jamais mis les pieds au
grotte de Lasco et après je suis assez
contre le principe de alors on parle des
plus belles destinations françaises on a
parlé du du du patrimoine
historique des bâtiments puisque le le
le site du monts-michel cumule un petit
peu un petit peu les deux je pense que
Philippe nous a assez bien explicité
l'intérêt là on est sur un pur pur site
naturel non aménagé donc la question
c'est est-ce qu'on peut le classer parmi
la plus belle destination française pour
moi la la réponse est oui parce que la
France c'est son patrimoine son
architecture et dans son patrimoine
évidemment son son patrimoine naturel et
ce patrimoine naturel je pense que la
grotte de lasasco est l'un des S oui en
fait sauf que c'est la grotte de l'ASCO
2 c'est une c'est une copie faim bien
sûr mais quand vous voyez le succès de
la grotte cquer par exemple à à
Marseille on sent bien qu' un intérêt
des gens pour ce genre de de destination
donc moi je trouve ça tout à fait
légitimeoui Val va falloir trancher je
ne sais pas si je vais trancher mais je
trouve que le fac similé est nécessaire
à la préservation de des œuvres par de
chacune des grottes je trouve aussi que
Cosker dont dont Florent vient de parler
qui se trouve à à Marseille et dans la
villa Méditerranée à côté du est un
succès pour autant on parle des plus
belles destinations françaises et là
pour moi la grotte de Lasco aussi
prodigieuse que soit sa copie ne fait
pas partie
des ça pose aussi un problème on n pas
on n'est pas obligé de tout visiter il y
a des choses non mais il y a des choses
qui doivent être aussi préservées on n
pas obligé de tout copier de tout rendre
accessible ça c'est le monde dans lequel
on vit il faut absolument qu'on puisse
aller partout effectivement Lasco peut
pas y aller parce que si on y va il y
aura plus de Lasco dans 20 ans donc on a
fait cette espèce de de
grotte oui mais on n'est pas obligé de
on n'est pas obligé on peut dire voilà
Lasco on ne le voit qu'en image on n pas
obligé d'y aller cette volonté toujours
de de vouloir à tout prix accéder à tout
je trouve ça insupportable alors late de
l'ASCO va-t-elle se retrouver derrière
ou devant si j'ai bien compris c'est
c'est un peu c'est la question là qu'on
va se poser maintenant mais le problème
c'est l'intitulé destination française
oui c'est pas une destination c'est pas
une destination c'est pas une
destination oui mais si si je vous dis
on part en weekend est-ce que vous
préférez partir en weekend à Nant ou
autour des grottes de Lasco benah ni
l'un ni
l'autre bon ben moi moi je vais trancher
je vais le mettre au-dessus de Nant et
30 mous voilà ou
voilà super et ben du coup je vais poser
maintenant la c'est c'est à Valérie je
crois de tirer on va le mettre auudessus
je vais m'en occuper tout de suite vous
allez le voir apparaître dans le tableau
c'est moyen technique incroyable oui
vous savez c'est très c'est très très
impressionnant Côte d'Azur Nice CAN et
cetera effectivement parce que Côte
d'Azure est forcément une grande
rassemble pas mal de choses can le
périmètre c'est largie là là c'est là
c'est une vraie destination si on parle
de la Côte d'Azur c'est une vraie
destination alors on pourrait en parler
pendant il faudrait 10 émissions parler
de la Côte d'Azur je vous rappelle que
il faut qu'on parle pas trop longtempsou
voilàà donc je pense que on n pas grand
chose à dire moi simplement sur il y a
une chose qui est très amusante à faire
c'est d'aller dans dans les
îles les îles de lesin et notamment
l'île c'est
saintemgueriteiteerite et saint-honora
voilà c'est sainte mararguerite qui est
qui est aux mains des moines non c'est
sa saint-honora voilà et saint-honora ça
c'est assez drôle et d'ailleurs c'est
assez drôle parce que les moines ont la
main sur les ils sont propriétaires de
la compagnie de de bateau qui va de
saint-honora à Cann et ça leur permet
j'avais discuté avec un moine quand
j'avais été là-bas ça leur permet de
verrouiller la la fréquentation et
justement d'éviter qu'il ait qu'il y ait
un trop plein voilà mais vraiment la
Côte d'Azur bon moi je pense qu'on peut
le
classer il y a pas grand chose à dire ça
reste quand même la grande c'est une
grande une des grandes destinations
français est-ce que vous préférez partir
en weekend au château de versaill ou sur
la Côte d'Azur voilà encore c'est pas
tout à fait c'est pas la même chose je
sais y a tellement de choix sur la Côte
d'Azur Philippe a souligné un aspect on
peut parler on peut parler des on peut
parler également de l'immédiia
arrièrepays qui a un intérêt assez
formidable et surtout moi je trouve que
c'est une destination qui est vraiment
plurielle c'est-à-dire qu'on peut la
découvrir en toutes les saisons avec des
intérêts qui sont qui sont différents ça
de la beignade à la randonnée en passant
par on va pas parler des musées mais
dans les villes comme Nice et cetera
c'est quand même en pleine en pleine
ébullition donc ça incarne également la
France je pense au peut-être pas autant
que le château de de Versailles mais je
pense que si vous posez la question à un
étranger la Côte d'Azur instinctivement
il vous le mettra dans les dans les
trois ou quatre donc moi je je me vois
pas le classer en dessous de de puis
peut-être qu'il faut se dépêcher d'y
aller avant qu'il fasse trop chaud
effectivement parce que c'est quand même
une destination a qu' mettre en 3ème
position en dessous du montmichel fait
moins bon vivre l'été maintenant allez
en dessous du monts-michel en dessous du
montsmichel c'est voté Biss c'est peser
euh Valérie je crois que c'est à vous de
tirer ou non non c'est à Florent c'est à
Florent c'est Valérie qui nous a offert
la Côte d'Azur euh moi je vous ramène à
l'ouest encore une fois je vous amène au
bassin d'Arcachon ah le Bassin
d'Arcachon alors il y avait dans la
liste bassin d'Arcachon il y avait la
dune duupila on a tout rassemblé puisque
c'est quand même dans la même zone
géographique qu'est-ce qu'on en pense de
la de la allez-y Valérie euh oui moi
j'avais rassemblé je voudrais pas
exclure la dune du Pila d'abord parce
que c'est un site extraordinaire qui est
qui a beaucoup souffert des des incendie
bien sûr on s'en rappelle euh on s'en
rappelle oui et que c'est une montagne
de sable unique unique en France qui est
un
véritable site d'archive archéologique
et on a encore retrouvé une des objets
qui ressortent comme ça la à la faveur
de des mouvements de de la terre et puis
c'est le Bassin d'Arcachon nous fait
nous fait rêver il y a un petit côté
exotique moi ça me fait penser aux
huîres et à l'épinette qu'on mange qu'on
mange ensemble enfin
malheureusement mange plus d'hre je
pense que là on est sur une des rares
destinations qu'on a tirer euh pour le
moment euh au sort qui correspond aussi
à mon sens à un art de vivre c'est un
art de vivre euh on va dans le bassin
d'Arcachon alors il a évidemment les
phénomènes naturels dont parle Valérie
hein c'est la plus grande dune d'Europe
devant le banc d'Arguin face au Cap
Ferré enfin on pourrait multiplier les
exemples d'un d'un environnement et
d'une nature qui sont encore une fois
exceptionnels hein ça je peut-être se
répéter mais ah il a que la France est
quand même un pays extraordinaire ce qui
me retient mon attention dans cette
destination c'est qu'elle est aussi à
mon sens étroitement associé à un art de
vivre voilà qui est qui est alors on est
dans le Sud-Ouest mais on est quand même
aussi près de Bordeaux euh on est dans
une région de vignoble on est dans une
région de de produits de la mer assez
assez exceptionnel donc des produits à
la fois simples raffinés qui
correspondent à un art de vivre à une
douceur de vivre et aussi une région je
tiens à le souligner qui est une région
sportive un peu comme on en parlait
d'Ancy donc voilà donc on va pas
simplement visiter des choses on va
vivre on va s'imprégner d'une atmosphère
euh c'est incontestable un site qui a
évidemment toute sa place et qui pour
moi mérite de F tout en haut de ce
classement vous parlez de 21e
arrondissement tout à l'heure 22e 23e au
bout d'un moment on vair on va voir ça
où est-ce qu'on le classe moi je serais
tenté de le mettre haut mais j'ai peur
que vienne du monde ah ben on verra
après c'est le jeu he ah je pense qu'ils
ont pas besoin de nous mais moi je le
mettre audessus d'île d'éron
ex Côte d'Azure ce qu'on a entendu que
la Côte d'Azur c'était très vaste donc
bien sûr bien sûr allez-y Philippe c'est
c'est à vous de tirer donc le top 3
château de versaill montsint-michel COD
d'Assur et donc alors puit du fou alors
moi j'ai j'ai jamais mis les pieds au
puit du fou c'est assez curieux mais
j'ai j'ai jamais eu l'occasion d'y aller
donc je peux absolument pas en parler
vous vous faites pas partie donc des
deux alors j'avais noté ça ça avant
parce que le le puis du fou dans le
dernier chiffre c'est 2,2 million ce
sera beaucoup plus encore en en en 2023
donc c'est un des des principaux sites
hors les sites parisiens qui sont
visités je mets de côté Disneyland Paris
don der exactement dont on parlera tout
à l'heure c'est quand même un succès qui
est incroyable et qui repose sur une
recette qui mêle histoire et spectacle
qui est quand même un cocktail
relativement inédit et qui fait briller
une région entière qui fait même vivre
j'irais pas jusque là parce qu'en
vendait il y a beaucoup d'entreprises
beaucoup de petites entreprises c'est
une région qui est assez dynamique de ce
point de vue-là mais c'est quand même un
parc qui est monté autour d'un concept
qui à l'époque pouvait paraître assez
abscon ou lointain et qui aujourd'hui
rencontre un succès qui est quand même
formidable qui fait parler de la France
dans le monde entier et de ce que j'en
entends c'est aussi une clientèle et un
public qui est très divers il y a
beaucoup de familles évidemment qui vont
pour profiter à la fois des spectacles
et de l'histoire puisqueon on picore un
petit peu tout ce qu'on veut et puis qui
a su monter autour tout un univers des
hébergements des spectacles des produits
dérivés et cetera qui à mon sens ont du
sens et dans ce top destination c'est
important de montrer qu' a pas que le
poids de l'histoire et que de manière
tout à fait contemporaine on peut créer
des sites et des destinations comm
celle-ci et pour moi le puit du Fou est
devenue une destination au sens où on y
reste aussi et on s'imprène de plusieurs
choses pour moi c'est la capitale de la
reconstitution historique réussie
d'accord
c'est c'est aussi un site qui réconcilie
avec l'histoire mais différemment de du
château de Versailles puisqu'on est dans
le spectacle vivant et ce sont des
fresques historiques qui sont à la fois
conduites par des professionnels des
comédiens professionnels des comédiens
amateurs mais amateurs éclairés euh qui
qui attire un
public plus ou moins averti mais qui
donne envie d'en savoir plus alors c'est
la ça donne une autre idée de de la de
la vender mais c'est c'est une réussite
touture il a été il a été primé c'est un
c'est un savoir-faire français ça aussi
exact après il y a pas tellement de
surtourisme puisque si tu si vous y
allez il faut que vous ayez un billet
exement donc justement ça en
plus
dénature pas des sites on fait vivre les
gens localement et C donc ça coche
toutes les cases alors où est-ce qu'on
met le pu du fou où est-ce que voulez le
classer c'est difficile parce que je le
mettrai après le lac quand même ah après
le lac Dancy après le la est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça en dessous du
château de Pierrefond Chau de piond moi
jeaurais mis auudessus de la BA de som
maisessus de la BA de som oui moi je
l'aurais mis audessus de la BA de Somme
ah ben je suis désolé flurent une
nouvelle fois j'ai pas de problème avec
la démocratie c'est la démocratie une
fois de plus j'entends parler de
privilège mais il y a la démocratie
aussi je constate que certains
privilèges n'ont pas été abolis écoutez
est-ce que ce classement vous vous
convient pour l'instant pour l'instant
ça va ou pour l'instant il convient en
tout cas on peut dire qu'il a belle
figure les châteaux de la Loire pas
château de la Loire on va oui on vaer
parlez vous si vous voulez non mais les
châteaux de la Loire il y en a 100 il y
en a une centaine donc t parler sans
parler du plus grand qui doit être quand
même Chambord au plus petit qui est
trous sec un tout petit château qui est
ravissant qui est minuscule et euh alors
entre les deux bah il y a 1000 il y a a
1000 châteaux non il y en a pas 1000 il
y en a 100 mais
euh voilà c'est comme la Côte d'Azur
j'allis dire personne n'a besoin de nous
pour pour vendre les châteaux de la
Loire il y a une chose qui est enfin les
grands châteaux de la Loire ont fait un
effort quand même ces dernières années
parce que ils étaient tous vides ça
c'est drôle hein les grands châteaux de
la Loire é VI pas ass de monde quiit VO
non vide vide
c'està-dire a pas me comme compienne
voilà comme compienne non non pas comme
compienne compienne c'est non comme
Pierrefond pardon pierre fond Pierrefond
parce comp Pienne qu' Pienne qu' Pienne
il y a très belle collection non non les
châteaux de alors là ils ont fait ils
ont fait un effort alors par exemple à
enoise il y a des il y a des il y a des
meubles qui sont arrivés ils ont ils
font du feu dans les cheminées comme à
Chambord pour donner un petit peu de vie
à tout ça après c des châteaux qui
étaient qui étaient vides qui n'avaient
pas de mobilier puisque on sait que le
roi que François 1er passait d'un
château à l'autre avec tout son mobilier
ses successeurs aussi euh euh voilà si
on avait un château à conseiller bah moi
j'aime beaucoup Amboise Amboise j'aime
beaucoup Amboise parce que Amboise c'est
la synthèse c'est c'est à la fois un
grand château historique et puis ça
reste un château privé c'est la
propriété de la de la
fondation du compte de Paris et euh et
ça la Fondation Saint-Louis et ça reste
et ça reste un château à taille humaine
avec un panorama extraordinaire sur la
Loire de la terrasse c'est là où est
enté Léonard de Vass alors c'est assez
rigolo parce que je ris c'est c'est pas
drôle mais mais mais en fait on est à
peu près persuadé que c'est pas Léonard
de
Vincy qui est là mais enfin bon il y a
quand même il y a quand même sa pierre
tombale mais on n'est pas sûr qu' qu'
soit il a laissé une œuvre ce ce ce
fabuleux ce fabuleux escalier que vous
connaissez
euh mieux que nous exactement euh donc
ce que je vous l'ai dit souligné aussi
pour compléter le le propos de Philippe
et j'ai vouséis un jeu de mot c'est
l'autre renaissance des des des châteaux
de la Loire grâce au Vél il y a des
véloroute qui sont développé alors qui
existaient déjà mais qui se développent
beaucoup trop parfois parce que c'est
aujourd'hui devenu des lieux
d'embouteillage mais c'est les châteaux
de la Loire comme souligné Philippe des
voilà il y a une centaine de châteaux
mais qui peuvent se visiter de
différentes manières notamment à vélo ce
qui en fait une escapade parce qu'on
parlait de destination tout à fait
sympathique à faire sous toute sous
toutes ses formes donc je trouve que
voilà je je
trouve une alternative à en prenant le
bateau et Loire oui oui alors c'est des
bateaux spéciaux c'est des bateaux à
fond plat et puis tu vas tu enfin on ne
passe pas direct enfin on descend pas
toute la
loi oui non ça se loue pas c'est des il
faut il faut qu' quelqu'un d'aguéri qui
qui navigue voilà ça s'organise donc a
différents v Chau de
Laire bons conseil alors la question
maintenant où est-ce qu'on le met où
est-ce qu'on met les châteaux de la
Loire c'est comme versaill tout ça quoi
c'est c'est vraiment les grands
classiques du tourisme français oui mais
est-ce que c'est des grands classiques
qui le valent est-ce
qu' Mo je mettrai quand même en 3è
position en 3è devant la Côte d'Azur on
enlève le soleil je
mettin de tête vous me faites plaisir je
sens qu'elle va descendre mais vous me
faites plaisir quand même euh allez-y je
crois que c'est à Valerie c'est à moi
bah c'est moi qui a tiré le non je sais
plus je viens de tirer les châteaux de
la
lo allez je me dvous est-ce que je vais
enfin vous faire bouger de
l'Ouest et bien non puisque il y a le
cap fréel le cap fr ah bah justement
c'est vous qui en parlez du Cap frel bah
toujours toujours pour moi on est dans
les dans les grands classiques on est
sur le le site naturel une région qui
gagne sans cesse des parts d'estime j'ai
pas besoin de dire part de marché parce
que aujourd'hui bah la Bretagne c'est
quand même une des régions les plus
fréquentées de France qui gagne des
touristes j'ajouterai quand même et
peut-être que le cap fr peut y
participer c'est peut-être une région
qui gagnera à découvert en dehors des
beaux jours voilà on a l'habitude de
dire la Bretagne on été alors maintenant
on va y chercher aussi à climat un pe le
fris en été mais vous voulez dire on va
y voir les tempêtes en hiver exactement
on peut aller voir les tempêtes en hiver
on peut y voir toute la la la la la
puissance de l'océan je pense c'est un
des lieux emblématiques qu'on peut aller
voir hors saison et puis se confronter
un peu à la à la puissance des éléments
voilà donc c'est c'est un un lieu tout à
fait emblématique et tout à fait
intéressant en toute saison j'insiste à
découvrir à découvrir à découvrir alors
cette découverte on la met où dans notre
classement alors moi c'est c'est
forcément plus pointu et anecdotique que
le reste du classement donc oui à la fin
la fin 14 donc ce sera ah donc derrière
Nant et derrière Nant et 30 mou c'est
pour vous éviter des problèmes avec les
nantés merci ils seront pas derniers
alors les gorges du Verdon dans lesquell
je ne suis jamais allé alors on va
demander d'être amis des Alpes les
gorges du Verdon on a la montagne on a
l'eau avec cette teinte si particulière
on a la confluence de deux départements
si j'ai bonne mémoire qui doivent être
les Alpes les Alpe d'Aure Provence ex
bass Alpe et puis Var ou ou ou vauclus
les gorges du vert GDON alors pareil le
le le pluriel et de rigueur puisqueen
réalité c'est une succession de gorge
avec des lacs des lacs au milieu c'est
un endroit qui est géologiquement
formidable qui est touristiquement très
intéressant parce qu'on peut y faire
toute une toute une plor d'activités qui
sont évidemment des activités lié à
l'eau mais qui sont aussi des activités
de randonnée des activités d'escalade
c'est un site pour le coup qui qui est
clairement frappé par le menacé par le
le le le surtourisme donc c'est un site
on peut découvrir en dehors des périodes
de fréquentation sauf que c'est quand
même un site naturel qui est
relativement fragile et qui est de plus
en plus réglementé donc on conseille aux
gens d'y aller mais pas trop ou bah de
de surtout de bien se renseigner sur ce
qui est possible de faire majestueux
c'est sinueux celui qui aime naviguer en
no vive y va et le surtourisme concerne
euh des des
sitesment des segments très particuliers
mais on peut avec le GPS euh voir où
vont les les les gorges pour éviter oui
les visiteurs où il y a un encombrement
on peut éviter ça c'est un site
absolument majestueux donc j'ai
l'impression que ça va être assez haut
dans notre classement ceux qui aiment le
voyage et la nature c'est c'est l'un des
plus beaux sites de France pour moi on
est d'accord on d'accord plus site de
France alors un des plus beaux sites de
France devant les châteaux de la Loire
derrière les château de la Loire euh
devant la Côte d'Azur je sais que ça a
rien à voir moi je le mettrai en 6 ou 7e
position quand même 6e position derrière
le Bassin d'Arcachon ouais derrière le
ou entre l'île deolyon et bellî entre
l'île de léron et bellî c'est vous qui
choisissez c'est vous les spécialistes
hein 7e para ça par 7e pour l'instant
très
bien euh je sais plus à qui c'est de TI
c'est à Valérie tirer
allez-y Marseille ah Marseille ben je
crois que ça tombe bien que soit vous
est-ce que je peux être juge et parti oh
oui oui oui vous l'inquiétez pas
certains l'ont déjà fait avant vous j'ai
l'impression Marseille c'est la plus
belle ville de France
ah plus belle ville grand club de foot
enfin on pe parler de part c'était pas
une destination touristique elle est
elle est devenue ou ça c'est vrai depuis
2013 depuis depuis qu'elle a été
capitale capit euréenne de la Culture en
2013 ou euh et c'est ce qui a changé son
visage et qui a rendu une certaine
fierté aux Marseillais ce sont c'est
Musem h euh
La La La Villa Méditerranée qui est
juste à côté dans l'ombre du Musem mais
dans la foulée euh sont redescendus
souvent de la capitale des Marseillais
et aussi pour pour ouvrir de la belle
hôtellerie ou pour y travailler pour
ouvrir des chambres d'ôutes euh oui il y
a des choses formidables en fait
Marseille est devenue désirable oui
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire parce qu'en fait c'est tout le
paradoxe de Marseille c'est d'être dans
la caricature on la présente comme le
Chicago je ne m'y suis jamais senti
français bien sûr en insécurité il y a
une telle actualité qu'on a deux ou
trois correspondants à Marseille au
Figaro maintenant oui qui ne vont pas
parler de tourisme mais nous avons aussi
une correspondante voyage qui nous fait
des des reportages magnifiques à
Marseille et qui là lui donne un un côté
glamour et est-ce que est- est-ce que
avant de classer vous nous donnez une
petite un petit endroit qui est pas
forcément très connu à Marseille et que
vous aimerez donner au à nos internautes
jeaim faire des ademis ah bah alors ou
alors vous le donnez pas et vous dites
que c'est un secret je sais pas vous
faites ce que vous
voulez c'est surtout que je ne sais pas
comment vous les vous les trouverez en
ligne les endroits mais mais je crois
que ce qui est intéressant de souligner
par rapport à par rapport à Marseille
parce qu'on a déjà beaucoup de choses
dans la région mais c'est complètement
légitime c'est une destination qui est
apparu apparu qui est apparu avec plus
de de force encore sur les radars
touristiques avec tout ce que tout ce
qu'on a souligné là aussi souligner
l'apport du train notamment depuis Paris
qui a aidé au rayonnement de Marseille
ouis ce qui est drôle c'est que quand on
arrive à la gare Saint-Charles euh après
il y a la Cannebière il y a le vieux le
port et puis après il y a plus rien il y
a la mer l'infini vous avez un lien avec
Marseille j'ai un lien avec Marseille
aussi et il y a il y a une c'est après
il y a plus rien c'est fini donc on a un
peu l'impression qu'on est descendu dans
le bas de la France ça on a l'impression
que la France se finit
là alors o commence
oui ça va être très compliqué à classer
Marseille oui c'est compliqué parce que
oui jeis quand même vous demander de le
faire puisque c'est quand même moi je le
mettrai avant le lac dency quand même
parce que je trouve que
c'est peut-être même avant la bê alors
pour le coup moi là-dessus que lac d'an
il y a quand même aussi une région qui
est formidable plein de choses à faire
autour je suis partagé là-dessus hein
qu'on a mis la bê somme trop j'hésite à
demander à Val tranché parce que c'est
la bê somme la bê somme nous gêne un peu
parce que Marseille c'est quand même
mieux que la bê somme enfin c'est une
vraie destination parce qu' il y a la
mer il y a
toutationation il y a la culture comme
dit Valérie il y a beaucoup de chos à
Marse dans ce caslà moi je vous propose
de baisser la bê somme en dessous d'Anou
et d'y mettre Marseille Marseille ça
paraî plus juste vous paraît plus juste
on fait comme ça bon très bien moiattant
que vous êtes content ça
me euh c'est à Florence de de tirer
maintenant allez est-ce que la
malédiction de l'Ouest malédiction
malédiction mais et ben Paysbasque ah le
Paysbasque PaysBas ça va aller vite
parce que le Pays-Bas que c'est non mais
parce que le Pays-Bas que c'est aussi
quand vous dit ça vous faites vous
faites un monologue non le Pays-Bas que
c'est bah il y a plusieurs pays-basques
il y a Biaritz il y a le il y a
l'arrière pays il y a saint
euh il y a les grandes plages il y a le
surf il y a beaucoup de
choses c'est c'est très riche le
Pays-Basque moi je dirais une chose
c'est que le Pays-Basque ce qui est
étonnant c'est que c'est un vrai
dépaysement là je parle en point de vue
de destination quand on est au pays-
basque on est vraiment nul par ailleurs
déjà par le temps hein parce qu'on n'est
jamais sûr qu'il fasse beau même tout au
long d'une journée c'est on se avec le
soleil on n'est jamais sûr qu'on se
couchera pas avec la
pluie oui c'est comme la Bretagne mais
au sud mais après c'est vrai que c'est
une une destination qui a une très forte
identité et qui l'a conservé parce que
dans beaucoup de destinations on a euh
ça s dilué voilà on a on a diluer les
identités dans un urbanisme qui
quelquefois n'était pas n'était pas très
adapté au Pays-Basque même les HLM sont
basque c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des il y a
des buissons d'ortensia devant ça il y a
il y a il y a il y a une culture basque
qui n'a jamais été trahi euh par les
politiques et je trouve ça et je trouve
ça ça donne du coup une destination qui
est vraiment très spécifique qui il y a
peu de destinations qui ont été aussi
peu dénaturé que le Pays-Basque cette
trésurgence identitaire dans le bon sens
du terme effectivement pour moi elle
mérite tout à fait d'être encouragé
parce que ce qu'on va y chercher c'est
effectivement un
dépaysement donc pour cette raisonlà
principalement je pense que c'est une
destination qui mérite d'être haut dans
le classement on va la classer haut
alors est-ce qu'on la classe au niveau
de la Côte d'Azur mon Saint-Michel moi
je la classerai avant la Côte d'Azur
avant la Côte d'Azur je trouve que c'est
plus c'est une vraie destination audaeux
derre derrière le Mont Saint-Michel
derrière oui quand même derrière le mon
sa-michel on le Pays-Basque audessus de
la Côte d'Azur c'est un peu la revanche
du Pays-Basque un peu la revanche
rche c'est la revanche du Pays Basque je
crois que c'est à vous de tirer non et
puis c'est mérité puis c'est mérité
effectivement Pays Basque alors
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça Carcasson ah
Carcasson c'était un c'est un souhait de
Florent dans château oui parce que
Carcassonne c'est il y a quand même plus
de 2 millions de personnes qui vont
visiter Carcassonne alors effectivement
spécifiquement pour pour son château
donc Carcasson c'est parfois sur des
routes de vacances c'est les gens qui
descendent dans le dans le Sud-Ouest
c'est parfois une destination en
elle-même parce qu'on a envie de faire
découvrir à ses enfants bah le le le le
concept d'un château fort qui reste
exceptionnel quand même c'est une ville
qui a su même si elle est relativement
pauvre mais mais mettre en avant ces ces
atoutsl donc moi pour toutes ces bonnes
raisons je pense que Carcasson mérite de
figurer dans ce classement alors je je
suis ouvert la discussion sur le la
position en revanche je pense c'est une
ville qui mérite tout à fait sa place
dans ce classement des des 30
destinations françaises je suis d'accord
d'abord c'est joli ou j c'est un décor
c'est
déc de cinéma c'est un décor et puis
c'est une destination fluvestre
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a le canal du du
midi juste à côté là aussi on peut et
naviguer et faire du vélo et visiter
ouais bien sûr bien sûr j Carcasson on
la voit de l'
d'autoroute il y a une a d'autoroute
ou on monte comme ça et alors on a tout
d'un coup il y a Carcasson apparaiss
comme à viignon c'est vraiment a des air
d'autoroute effectivement la voiture l'
des pén
d'im d'utoroute qui
mér alors devant la BA on va quand même
mettre derrière Marseille j'ai bien
l'impression au niveau à ce niveaul
derrière Marseille au-udessus de la BA
de som ça vous va oui est-ce que c'est
bonussi la BA de som à ce rythme là va
va tomber écoutez moi je pense que la BA
somme faut tout de suite qu'on la mette
à la 30e position ah mais alors je vous
prévi je vous préviens je vous préviens
qu'il y a 35 nons et que peut-être
queelle va disparaître du classement
c'est possible allez à vous
Valérie nous partons en camarg ah la
Camargue va éviter la saison des
moustiques ah oui bah la Camargue est
connu pour ses moustiques mais pas que
il y a quand même ch à y voir très belle
chose à y voir pas que les flamaments
roses la camarque puisque vous vous
soullignez qu'il fallait être de plus en
plus sélectif he vous voyez la liste la
liste qui s'étofre moi la Camar je
personnellement je la ferai pas figurer
dans ce classement je pense que entre
les sites culturels les sites plus
patrimoniaux il y a il y a suffisamment
de de sites en France et s'il fallait
être sélectif moi la camarg
personnellement je la mettrai pas dans
ce al je suis pas du tout d'accord avec
vous parce qu'il y a un écosystème en
camarg avec un un aller-retour entre la
mer entre les j'allais dire les eaux
salées les
eaux et l'intérieur des terres qui est
unique en France le ça a façonné non
seulement un territoire une géologie un
tempérament c'est aussi un art de vivre
avec avec les manades avec les taureaux
avec les gardiens enfin c'est pzv je pas
le le le ce ce qui est embêant ce qui
est embêtant si on élimine si on élimine
des destinations françaises euh la
Camargue euh c'est qu'on élimine par
exemple eggmort et par exemple egmort
c'est une splendeur je dire c'est c'est
vraiment s'il y avait peut-être une
ville qu'il faudrait aller voir dans le
sud c'est vraiment egmort parce que
egmort c'est la ville de Saint-Louis
bien sûr mais euh elle a préservé ses
remparts là encore il y a aucun immeuble
enfin aucune construction même récente
qui dépasse des remparts ce qui est
assez remarquable et euh on l'a on en
franchit les portes comme peut-être
Saint-Louis l'a fait et et je trouve que
c'est un peu dur après je suis aussi
d'accord avec Valérie la camarque c'est
un art de vivre c'est c'est de la
couleur c'est faut l'appliquer à toutes
les destinations du classement quasiment
hein non non non parce que c'est c'est
précisément comme le Pays-Basque une
destination euh identité cult qui a une
identité culturelle qui est très forte
qui a conservé ses qui a conservé ses
rit qui a conservé un certain nombre de
rendez-vous non moi je suis je suis pas
d'accord avec par Rapp ver deç moi je le
mettrai avant le lac d'y avant le lac
d'y oh là là FL vous pouvez pas le
mettre audessus de lac dan non
c'estant je mets un V avant la B avant
la B allez avant la bê somme j'ai
l'imession que la bê som n'est pas
forcément la plus aimée de paix notre
notre juge de paix c'est à Florent
Florent va-t-on partir de l'Ouest allez
est-ce que bah là on était pas dans
l'ouest on rest à chaque fois depuis
rokamadour j'ai la main euh j'ai la main
heureuse oui alors
rokamadour c'est le je crois que c'est
un 2e ou 3e site de France le plus
visité alors c'est pareil rokamadour
c'est la même chose que le monts-michel
hein c'est un site naturel prodigieux
encore plus beau quand on le voit de
loin que quand on y est c'est un site un
peu troglodite il y a trois niveaux il y
a le village alors pareil que que le
monts-michel beaucoup de de de marchands
du temple qui vendent n'importe quoi du
mdine China un peu partout et il y a un
étage intermédiaire qui est la cité
sacrée et qu'est-ce qu'il y a de plus
beau hein puisqu'il y a SEP sanctuaires
euh euh autour dont le tombeau du moine
Amadour euh d'où le nom du rocher
d'Amadour du rock d'Amadour
et et ce ce niveau-là il a été
entièrement préempté par les religieux
qui sont les seuls à le faire visiter et
même même l'Office de Tourisme n n'y
rentre pas avec ces avec avec ses
visites donc du coup on est accueilli
par des scoutes on est accueilli par Al
qui font pas par des prêtres et cetera
qui font pas du prosélitisme mais du
coup ça permet de conserver l'identité
de ce site qui est un site marial qui
était le site qui était le grand
pélerinage français qu'on fait tous les
rois de France à genoux et un grand
escalier avec des centaines de marches
que que alors on revient à Saint-Louis
que Saint-Louis et sa mère Blanche de
Castille ont gravier à genou et donc euh
euh le il a gardé cette spécificité ça a
pas été dénaturé al ce qui est assez
remarquable parce que c'est un peu comme
une espèce de de vague de touristes qui
vient se briser surokamadour mais qui
n'inonde pas la partie la plus belle la
partie sacrée et puis je disais qu'il y
avit trois niveaux le troisième niveau
c'est l'ancienne résidence des évêques
de de cor qui est un château qui a été
restauré par Violet le Duc et euh sur
lequel on on marche sur les rempards
donc il y a une vue absolument
prodigieuse sur sur tout l'environnement
et alors là là là là c'est beaucoup plus
c'est beaucoup plus touristique un
tourisme beaucoup plus basique donnevie
mais je ne connais pas mais là ça me
donne envie alors où est-ce que vous
très beau où est-ce que vous voulez le
le classer rokamadour
Philippe les plus belles dtinations
françaises rokamadour de Pierrefond
peut-être oui au-dessus de Pierrefond
allez ce sera donc au-dessus de
Pierrefond pour rokamadour allez-y euh
Philip je crois C PhIP de Philip de
tir on essaie de faire assez
court je vais rejeter celui que ah vous
voyez qu' fait sortir de de la liste
destination alors Lille Lille la ville
de Lille la de l est une destination
touristiqueaime beaucoup l où et où
doitelle alors c'est un peu ce que
disait Valérie tout à l'heure fait
partie de ces destinations comme
Marseille quand tu étais révélé
notamment quand elle était capitale
culturelle de l'Europe c'était en 2002
c'est assz assez ancien mais elle a
capitalisé làdessus ouis elle a
capitalisé là-dessus bon il y a eu on
l'a dit 25 fois le la restauration du
vieux lî par Pierre montroi quand il
était maire euh et c'est vrai que c'est
une ville qui a quand même c'est c'est
une ville méridionale au nord de la
France c'est ça qui est assez
sympathique c'est que quand on est à lî
l'été par exemple ou au printemps on est
vraiment dans une ville méridional c'est
il y a les il y a les terrasses de café
les gens boivent les gens se parlent
c'est très convivial et ceeta c'est
vraiment pe image qu'on a cultivé
pendant des années du Nord voilà et puis
après c'est une destination culturelle
très importante parce que il y a un très
beau musée des beauard il y a tout le
temps de multiples donc ça mérite
d'être direct en fait on pe rejoindre l
à Marseille l'Î à Marseille est-ce que
est-ce que oui moi je trouve que c'est
des destins à chacune d'une manière
différente mais c'est céouou on peut
mettre à côté est-ce qu'on met Marseille
et Lille c'est une forme
d'encouragement que les villes se
révèlent comme ça au sud Valérie je vous
laisse je mettrai Marseille Mo je
mettrai Marseille mettrai Marseille
audessus quand même oui parce que
Marseille marseilleessus Marseille
audessus et vous pouvez piocher
exactement plus complète voilà comme ça
donne quand même les sous-titres bordeau
la ville de Bordeaux Bordeaux qu'est-ce
que le 21e arrondissement de Paris hein
vous le disiez donc non non c'est pas
c'était pas de Bordeaux je disais ça
mais le bah Bordeaux là encore c'est
quand même des grands classiques du
tourisme français pareil c'est une ville
qui
a qu'on a redécouvert grâce à l'action
de de son maire de l'époque qui était à
lainjupé et qui a vraiment sorti la
ville mais ça ça fait partie de ces
villes effectivement qui ont été tirées
vers la lumière grâce tout d'un coup à
un homme qui qui les qui les a incarné
qui a trouvé les qui a trouvé le bon
filon pour pour ça c'est une ville qui
rassure oui c'est une ville qui rassure
c'est bah c'est une un grand ensemble
c'est je crois le plus grand ensemble
français du 18e siè siècle côté
historique côté
architecture voilà et c'est la il y a la
cité du vin moi la cité du vin c'est
parce que je préfère à Bordeaux mais et
après il y a il y a un côté que moi
j'aime beaucoup à Bordeaux il y a le il
y a ce port de la Lune donc cette espèce
de courbe cet urbanisme qui est très
beau on a on a un peu l'impression
quelquefois d'être à Saint-Pétersbourg
il y a il y a un côté bord de la Neva et
puis il y a aussi tout un Bordeaux alors
sur l'autre rive donc la rive droite qui
est un bordeau un peu plus un peu moins
classique à peu moins avec des avec des
friches industrielles qui ont été qui
ont été reconquises et où il y a une
même une hôtellerie qui est un peu plus
écolo un peu plus un peu plus un peu
plus amusante un peu plus fun et et et
cette ça fait que je veux dire qu'on qui
qu'on soit euh on peut vraiment
découvrir des choses à Bordeaux qui vous
corresponde c'est une vraie belle
destination oui c'est une vraie belle
destination je vais mettre un seul véau
je trouve ça reste une ville très
minérale une ville qui est resté très
minérale et je trouve que par rapport à
l'ensemble des villes qu'on a évoqué
pour le moment voilà un petit retard
làdusseille est bien plus minéral que
Marseille est vraiment la mer donc sauve
un petit peu un c'est une ville qui a
peu de de d'arbre elle est très peu
arboréoui
voisis côté très minéral de B Marse et
Bordeaux à côté oui voilà
ou est-ce que je mets bordeau entre l en
dessous de l'île moi je mettrai avant lî
quand avant l avant l grandtination
derrière Marseille
Prim le foot de Marseille et puis l'oval
bordolaise pour l'ovall pour l'Ovalie
aussi
allez
FL ce top 30 décidément Toulouse
Toulouse on va on reste dans le sud on
reste avec une grande ville du Sud j'ai
envie de vous poser la question alors il
va falloir savoir où on Classe Toulouse
par rapport à Bordeaux parce que ça a
mal Vieli justement s'il y avait un
constat à faire moi je serais assez de
la vie de de la vie de Philippe la la le
manque de dynamique peut-être sur le sur
le tempsou manque d'attractivité manque
de dynamisme sur le temps la ville est
belle c'est une très belle ville mais il
y a pas la il y a plus la même qualité
enfin il y a pas la même qualité de vie
je trouve que la même attractivité en
tout cas peut-être qualité de vie c'est
peut-être un peu dur mais la même
attractivité qu'à Bordeaux ou à
Marseille c'est une ville qu'on a moins
envie de découvrir c'est une ville qui
reste un peu brouillon un peu disons que
s'il y avait un choix à faire c'est pas
celle qu'on cocherait serait
certainement dans les petites envies
qu'on peut Mar pas pour moi elle est
associée à nouaro ouais oui c'est aussi
une chanson oui bien sûr et puis
sincèrement dans une région il y a quand
même beaucoup de concurrence alors c'est
dommage en fait il faudrait qu'elle se
réveille Toulouse il faudrait qu'elle se
réveille on peut la mettre bas on peut
la mettre bien en dessous de ou moi je
la mettrai peut-être après la Camargue
après la Camargue en dessous de la
sur la Camar quand même Ramad on n'a pas
réussi à dépasser la B somme mais bon
voilà vous en tirez les conclusions que
vous voulez allez- Philippe vous pouvez
tirer un prochain papier moins en moins
et non il y en a de moins en moins il
reste des petits disneland de Paris ça
tombe bien parce que j'ai horreur de dis
Paris je trouve que tout est peutever du
classement il y a pas de je trouve que
les couleurs c'est pas notre culture je
trouve que les couleurs sont criardes
les spectacles sont vulgaires les
attractions sont mais au mauvais sens du
terme je déteste Disneyland Paris les
hôtels je trouve qu' sont moches mais
vraiment c'est vraiment la culture
américaine dans ce qu' là de plus laid
et et je n'aime pas cette je n'aime pas
cette destination alors en plus c'est
vraiment un truc de masse c'estent
effrayant ENF je va répondre au
procureur je suis un peu radical je dois
reconnarement le privilège s'appelle
Fast Pass il apprécie beaucoup moins
mais Disneyland est-ce que ça vocation à
être beau non est-ce que ça vocation à
représenter un peu de la France pas
forcément mais je suis pas d'accord avec
vous parce que le Parc Astérix par
exemple c'est beau le Parc Astérix les
les couleurs les
reconstitutions
terin oui il y aura le paret qui va
tomber bientôt donc il va Disney la
question c'est qu'est-ce qui attire
autant autant Disney la seule chose
qu'on peut regretter c'est voilà des
étrangers qui viennent en France oui ou
oui nous la question c'est c'est le top
30 desation française la question c'est
est-ce que vous conseillez à les
étrangers de venir à dis de Paris
évidemment que si en fait pour moi c'est
une destination Disney c'est pas une
destination franaise bien et bien du
coup on peut le mettre on peut mett tout
en bas du
classement et je le mettrai après le CAP
fr après le CAP oui moiussi je suis
d'accord avec Valérie parce que c'est le
top des destinations françaises moi je
ne dirais pas un
étranger enfin non mais c'est pas une
question si on suit leur logique et
comme je suis démocrate je je je vais
les suivre mais moi personnellement je
l'aurais mis beaucoup plus haut dans le
Clement mais non c'est c'est une c'est
pas une destination française on reste
on reste en France c'est une destination
américaine en France ça rien à voir
resteance une construction c'est une
constructionement allez-y Valérie je
suis ravi vous on sent le vous avez
trouvé des alliés de votre on sent le ou
je vois ça je vois ça sur les internaut
pour nous défendre on va voir ce que on
dirait un fait exprès la Provence la
provencece après Marseille ben vous
pouvez en parler c'est tellement vaste
alors oui par c'est c'est vrai que c'est
vaste c'est le problème de ces de ces de
ces régions on a voulu rentrer parce
qu'il y a beaucoup c'est c'est comme un
mot consensuel qui va être contre la
Provence oui tout le monde a son avis
sur la Provence quelle est la vôtre moi
quand je pense moi je pense moi je pense
alors je donne pas mon avis mais moi
quand je quand quand on me parle de
Provence je pense au mon Ventou je pense
au champ de la Vand est-ce que c'est une
bonne
définition oui là on est à la veille de
Noël moi je pense au 13 dessert voilà
c'est très divers la province Frédérique
Mistral avait donné une définition assez
extensive et assez longue de ce de ce
territoire je pense quand même tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire que c'est
un territoire formidable et cetera si on
suit notre logique notamment celle qu'on
a exprimé sur le Pays-Basque qui est de
continuer à se développer tout en
tentant de garder son identité je pense
que la province elle est un peu en
retrait personnellement ouais oui moi je
suis assez d'accord il y a plusieurs
provinces la bon évidemment
Saint-Rémi tout ça les les beau de
Provence c'est bon c'est vraiment les
les les les tartes à la crème
touristique mais ça reste quand même ça
reste quand même assez beau mais là où
je suis d'accord avec Florent c'est que
c'est un c'est un territoire qui a été
beaucoup trop urbanisé un peu Disneyland
parfois euh oui parfois un peu
Disneyland effectivement un peu un pe un
peu Senton un peu ma elle s'est endormie
sur ses lauriers c'était trop facile
peuttre peut-êtreors elle avait trop
d'atou elle n'a pas assez travaillé
selon moi alors c'est vous m'avez dit la
même chose pour Toulouse figurez-vous et
ben alors c'est pas mal mettons monsla
derrière Toulouse avant et av comme
ça moi j'ai j'ai j'ai pas de sujet sur
ce qu'on bouge le classement mais au
moins qui est une cohérence et ça me
paraît cohérent de dire la Provence
voilà on la récompense pas on lui donne
pas une prime pour toutes les raisons
qu'on a qu'on a évoqué ici ce sera
derrière Toulouse allezy Flor Florent
d'y aller et bien la malédiction de
l'Ouest va-t-elle se
poursuivre je l'interromps avec Lyon ah
la ville de Lyon encore une grandille
ville c'est la ville où je suis NIS ah
Philipe est-ce que vous voulaz défendre
Lyon pour commencer oui alors Lyon oui
c'est une très oui ben Lyon c'est comme
c'est comme le reste de la c'est comme
les les trois ville qu'on a qu'on a
sélectionné c'est comme Marseille
Bordeaux Lille Lyon c'est une c'est une
vraie destination c'est une destination
gastronomique c'est une destination
culturelle c'est une destination
architecturale c'est c'est une très très
belle ville alors le lion de mon enfant
c'est existe plus vraiment le liyon un
peu des mystères est-ce que toute façon
lion va se retrouver dans ce classement
au côté de Marseille bordeau Lille oui
moi je oui il y a pas
tellementgter làdessus bah il faut le
mettre entre Marseille et Bordeaux par
exemple parce que c'est quand même la
entre Marseille et Bordeaux oui c'est
quand même une ville importante devant
Marseille oui oui peut-être pr une
spéciale à la qualité de vie ou je l'
rejoint l'aménagement des qu les
picyclab les efforts sur les
déplacementve extérieurement son musée
assez moche et quand même une
gastronomie il faut quand mêmeuen Musée
des Confluences extérieurement oui
extérieurement c'est pas c'est quand
même une allez-y Philippe vous pouvez
vous vous pouvez piocher al il y en a
bientôt plus nous nous dépêchons pour
terminer oui pour terminer à l'heure on
avait dit qu'on qu'on allait faire durer
ça 1 heure je je sais Valérie je
Courchevel Courchevel et les Alpes alors
beaucoup de choses à dire sur courev
alors Courchevel moi je l'avais défendu
parce que je je je disais que c'est l'
il y a toutes les il y a beaucoup de
station donc pourquoi plus Courchevel
que Mary belle que que valdizer je ne
sais quoi mais cour je trouve qu'il y a
un
imaginaire autour de Courchevel il y a
quelque chose de d'un peu inaccessible
d'un peu voilà d'un peu hors du temps
Courchevel c'est la c'est la reine des
c'est un peu la reine des Alpes c'est
une Valérie employée tout le mot de
désirer c'est une station qu'on désire
après la réalité est pas pas forcément
au rendez-vous il y a plusieurs
Courchevel parce qu' il y a plusieurs
Courchevel il y a plusieurs il faut
expliquer à ceux qui connaissent pas
qu'il y a plusieurs niveaux de
Courchevel le plus connu Courchevel
n'est pas que snob Courchevel n'est pas
que snob ça reste quand même très snob
parce que soit on est au bon niveau et à
ce moment-là on le dit soit on est dans
les autres niveaux et à ce moment-là on
dit qu'on est à Courchevel sans préciser
est à
1850 euh parce que quand on pense à
courchevell on pense évidemment à
l'hiver et Courchevel c'est quand même
le plus grand domaine skiable d'Europe
les Trois Vallées donc on peut
fréquenter Courchevel en étant dans
d'autres stations en venant même à la
journée ce qui à la journée pourquoi pas
donc je je je je concède l'appartenance
à ce cl
cour représenter en partie la montagne
français avant de le classer je regrette
que Courchevel a remplacé le massif du
Montblanc parce que je crois que c'est
le cas oui c'est après peut on peut
rajouter le massif du Montblanc mais
parce que le massif du Mont-Blanc c'est
un peu enfin c'est massif de Montblanc
c'est un peu large quoi alors c'est un
peu large oui et non alors c'est vrai
que je le regrettais parce que parce
qu'on va parler bientôt dans dans le
journal des des station alpine olympique
dans notre série diverse dont chamoni et
qu'il y a pas mal de chamonar en effet
alors c'est peut-être le lien pas mal de
Chamonard sont allé fonder Courchevel
regrettant le soleil à chamoni et le
trouvant à Courchevel ouais non mais
Courchevel c'est aussi une histoire
française hein c'est une une station à
l'origine qui a une vocation d'ailleurs
plus plutôt plutôt sociale dans le le
conseil départemental de sa est toujours
actionnaire c'est c'est une histoire de
la montagne française Courchevel je
rejoins Valérie sur le fait que chamoni
aussi peut-être d'ailleurs davantage on
va quand même fêter les les 100 ans euh
des des pr je cré un ticket chamoni cour
chevel si vous voulez non ça marche pas
ça ne marchera pas
Mar ça peut pas aller ensble Clement
mais je
Gard ça commena bien où estce que vous
voulez le mettre mais est-ce qu'on met
chamoni ou est-ce qu'on met montbanc non
mais non met Courchevel et non mais
Courchevel il faut quand même le classer
mais je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
avec ce que disait Flor assz drôle parce
que c'est ça a été créé ou c'est
histoire franaise c'est une histoire
française mais ça été créé comme une
destination populaire ex c'est devenu la
destination la plus chic des Alpes
français plus ch d'aille avant je peux
me permettre quand même pas beaucoup de
montagne moi je je je la ferai quand
mêmeu avant lein avant le Bassin
d'Arcachon ah oui après les châaux de la
très bien c'est de nos champions
français quand même alors je crois qu'il
y a un peu de montagne qui arrive encore
je laisse je vous laisse tirer
Valérie voulez je vais tirer les
prochains comme ça au moins pour pour
accélérer parce que le parc alors est-ce
que le Parc Astérix au niau PHPP
Philippe va être content non mais c'est
pas une questionêtre content mais le
parc gterrix euh bah raconte notre
histoire parce que ça raconte l'histoire
des Gaulois et je trouve que c'est donc
assez français je trouve que
esthétiquement ils ont fait beaucoup
d'efforts au départ c'était pas très
beau et puis euh d'abord ça s'est quand
même installé en forêt le Parc Astérix
hein donc il y avait une forêt
préexistante euh donc il y a beaucoup
d'arbres il y a beaucoup de nature moi
je trouve que c'est très agréable quand
on se prène avec des avec des jeunes
enfants au parc Astérix h parce que
voilà a des paysages c'est joli et puis
la culture gauloise c'est assz beau
c'est pas la culture américaine c'est
des références qui nous parlent voilà
c'est Astérix as un peu d'histoire
beaucoup de divertissement donc en
résumé on est entre le puit du fou je
regr encore laés après le le bémol que
je mettrai quand même sur le par as pour
être tout à fait objectif c'est que
c'est c'est difficilement
accessible parce que c'est loin il y a
pas de il y a pas de transport en commun
vraiment ou alors faut prendre des
navettes qui partent de la de la place
de de la de l'étoile
je ou de la Porte Maillot et c'est vrai
qu'il y a pas voilà mais en même temps
c'est mieux préservé du coup populaire
alors où est-ce qu'on le classe grotte
de Lasco vers le GRTE de Lasco est-ce
que plus haut est-ce que moi le sujet
moi je je le mettrai aux environs
Disneyland pareil la question c'est
qu'on metessus DISY après tu dis on se
parvec ce que m'a dit Philippe ça
pouvait pas je mettrai après le vigob de
champagne c'est moi qui tire maintenant
comme ça met après Disney je alors je
l'ai mis avant Disney je l'ai mis alors
il risque de disparaître hein de toute
façon de ce classement le vigob de
champagne est-ce que c'est une
destination touristique le vigob de
champagne bah qu'on soit la question
c'est quand français ou étrangers est-ce
qu'on se dit est-ce qu'une fois dans ma
dans dans dans mon existence euh je
m'égare je choisis de m'égarer dans le
vinop de champagne pour découvrir des
des destinations très peut-être très
diverses et puis aussi ce qui correspond
une forme d' d'art de vivre à la
française donc est-ce qu'il doit être
dans ce classement la réponse est oui et
où il doit être dans ce classement c'est
une petite partie du patrimoine français
dans un espace naturel qui est plutôt
agréable mais qui pour moi sort pas non
plus des des canons esthétiques qu'on a
vu plus haut donc pour ces raisonsl
après la B som voilà après la B som
quelqu'un qui est derrière la B ça
représente la
France oui moi les caves de Champagne je
les trouve absolument prodigieuses le
vignoble alors nous avons maintenant
etrota trop de monde trop de monde à
eteta ah alà est-ce que trotard etetard
je trouve que c'est une destination qui
est qui est resté un
peu un peu dans son jus qui a pas qui a
jamais vraiment beaucoup décollé
beaucoup évolué qui a du mal d'ailleurs
à retenir je crois ses à retenir ses ses
visiteurs il y a un très beau jardin qui
a été créé par des Russes des oligarques
russes euh dans éretard juste sur la
hauteur d'êre tard oui mais quand on
parle d'êre tard on pense surtout à ses
à ses fais oui à ces falaises oui mais
en fait ça fait c'est
petit voilà c'est ça c'est très
petit on y reste pas forcément trè pas
parce que il y a pas grandchosees est-ce
que est-ce que ça va à je pense qu'il
faut aller à fécan et aller voir
êreetard alors fécan est beaucoup plus
intéressant qu'être tard parce que il y
a beaucoup plus de choses V qui a été
une étape de la Solitaire du Figaro oui
aussi ce qui vient de dégringoler au
classement donc c'est évidemment une
destination intéressante mais capfel
vers le capfel
ouiessusous enessous moi moi
personnellement je mettrai en
dessous du Cap frel on continue
saint-malot oh saintmo Saint-Malo
Saint-Malo la cité corsaire est-ce qu'on
peut est-ce que Saint-Malo aujourd'hui
représente le le le problème c'est que
Saint-Malo on se demande si c'est pas
devenu Disneyland je cro qu' a plus un
seul commerce
de bouche pour cet ennui justement le
manque de réinvention je crois qu'il y a
quelques années il y a pas de
gourmandise on n pas envie d'aller à sa
pour les écrivains
voyageurs voilà ilapparaîtra même pas
dans ce classement rappelez-vous
Philippe il y avait un projet de de
musée signé tada qui avait pas qui était
pas allé au bout pour toutes ces bonnes
raisons là justement trop touristique
mérite pas d'être dans classement alors
nous avons maintenant la Corse la Corse
toujours alors c'est un peu comme la
voilà c'est extrêmement vague euh al
l'idée l'idée c'est de pas sauter hein
donc on va on va pas la mettre non plus
trop
basse attention atttion c'est de rester
en vie voilà tout
simpement la Corse la cor ces quatre
saisons pense évidemment au plagees cors
qui sont excusez-moi mais c'est c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable on va parler
d'une identti est-ce qu'on mettrait au
niveau de
la oui oui moi je le
mettraius la c c par rapport au basque
on en pense quoi alors les cores
vontouver avec les basque il v être he
ah oui c'est drôle c'est drôle non non
mais c'est pas gênant moi je mettra oui
oui
en moi je le mettrai quand même audessus
permettez-moi mais je encore pas être
d'accord avec la majorité mais je le
mettrai audessus parce que la Corse en
quatre saisons il y a quand même en plus
des randonnées
extraordinaires je pe je peux changers
singulière parle de destination il faut
être honnête la Corse voilà il faut
mettre auudessus une vra des tion et ben
écoutez on va le mettre auudessus il
nous en reste deux il nous en reste deux
il nous reste on va peut-être pas
commencer par ça on va commencer par le
Pic du Midi parce que on veut de la
montagne Florent nous en aous en a parlé
un peu de pyénée un peu de pyrénée quand
même il en fallait où est-ce qu'on place
le pic du midi alors un peu un peu
beaucoup de Pyréné parce que ça c'est
c'est un site c'est un site naturel
c'est ai un site scientifique le Pic du
Midi donc
c'est c'est le plus beau site pour
observer les étoiles c'est un lieu
incroyable qui raconte les
transformations au sens large compris
les transformations touristiques parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu un lieu qui
est
relativement accessible le pic du midi
il mérite tout à fait d'être présent
déjà pour récompenser le fait que les
Pyrénées sont par rapport aux albes je
trouve une chaîne de montagne qui a su
vraiment attirer des gens en toute
saison pour des raisons qui peuvent être
thermal pour des randonnées qui sont
quand même très chouettes et cetera donc
le le le Pic du Midi a toute sa
les Pyrénées pardon toute leur place et
le Pic du Midi mérite d'être classé et
classé à mon sens plutôt haut parce que
c'est aussi un encouragement à découvrir
voilà cette cette
chaîevel aprèsou avant Mo je mettra
après courev on on va le mettre après
après Courchevel et j'ai un dernier nom
à vous montrer ce sera la ville de Paris
qui restait puis c'est un petit petit
papier c'est pas truqué hein c'est
vraiment en tire en dernier on le tire
en dernier donc où est-ce qu'on met
Paris par rapport à tout ça avant la bês
quand même est-ce bah c'est difficile
parce que Paris bon c'est quand même
Paris malgré toutes les tout ceon tout
ce tout ce dit tout ce qu'on en dit
est-ce est-ce que est-ce qu'on le met
dans les villes est-ce qu'on le met dans
enfin vous rendez pas compte que Paris
c'est la c'est la ville enfin c'est une
des plus belles villes du monde et c'est
la ville qui
concentre une part une part de la
culture de l'humanité on part de là donc
donc donc vous voulez le mettre tout en
haut audessus du château de versaill ça
mériterait d'être
malgré malgré malgré les polmies et
malgré tout ce qu'on peut regretter sur
ce qui s passe et bien écoutez merci
beaucoup est-ce que ce classement vous
convient château de versaill en 1 le
Monte Saint-Michel en 2 pardon Paris en
1 du coup château de Versailles en 2 le
mont SaintMichel en 3 la Corse en 4 le
Pays-Basque en 5 la codeazure en 6 et
après je vous laisse faire le classement
est-ce que ce classement vous convient
ou c'est parfait et ben écoutez merci
beaucoup à tous d'avoir été là de sêtre
prêté à ce jeu Merci à VOUS du Figaro
d'avoir été nombreux à nous suivre dans
un instant vous aurez rendez-vous avec
la question du jour sur le site du
Figaro bonne
journée